Sometimes I’ll be scrolling
through my social media on my phone,
and I'll get an ad.
But how on Earth do they know
that sometimes I snore so loudly
my brother needs to wear earplugs
the next room over?
I think we're all familiar
with this not-so-secret habit
of the tech industry,
where they use these complex algorithms
to get to know who we are,
what we like, what we don't like.
Also, they can tailor ads to us
and sell us things.
But what if we could use
this technology for good?
When I was diagnosed
with depression in 2015,
I had multiple intense suicidal episodes.
At one point, it actually got so bad
that I spent the whole day planning out
how I would die later that evening.
I was probably less than an hour away
from ending my life
when something saved me.
What was it?
Someone reached out.
I now know that I'm not alone,
where in Australia, suicide
is the leading cause of death
for individuals aged
between 15 to 44 years old.
And for every single suicide death,
there are 25 to 30 times
the number of attempts.
Our recent research has even shown us
that less than half of people
who attempt suicide
will actually reach out for help prior,
meaning that if we are to reach them,
we need to meet them where they are.
I'm now a researcher who tries
to understand, how can we do this?
And the research tells us that people,
most people who attempt suicide
or even think of suicide,
don't actually want to die.
In fact, they're looking for any
reason to continue on living.
But what that tells us
is that any sort of interruption,
whether it's a tap on the shoulder,
a text message or even an internet pop-up,
could potentially save someone's life.
So for me, the question then becomes,
how do we do this in a better way?
How can we reach out in a more effective,
rapid and far-reaching manner?
Well, we have great hotlines
and emergency services in Australia,
but they still require the individual
to take the first step.
But another thing is,
how on Earth are we supposed to know
what a person’s thinking
or feeling if they're not speaking up?
One way is through
their search behaviors.
Because you and I both know
we've searched things up on the internet
that we would never
ask another living soul.
(Laughter)
Our struggles about suicide
are no exception.
And the research actually supports this.
For example, in one study,
the investigators went up
to these individuals
who had recently attempted suicide
and asked to see their
anonymized search history.
And in fact, these individuals
had searched up keywords
pertaining to suicide means
and methodology
as well as surrounding
hopelessness and loneliness.
Another finding that supports this
and has been found
in many different countries,
for example, in Japan, US and Taiwan,
is that the volume of internet searches
for suicide-related terms
actually correlates
with the national suicide rate.
In a completely different field,
they found that us Australians,
we spent about 40 hours a week
on the internet.
And 93 percent of the time
it starts on a search page.
So could it be that the search page
be an ideal place to intervene?
That's why in many countries,
including Australia,
if you search up suicide-related
terms on the internet,
you'll see a hotline banner,
which is great,
but the research shows
that not everybody on the verge
of taking their life
wants to call a hotline.
It's not as easy as picking up
a phone and calling.
Internationally, many countries
still don't have a sustainable hotline,
and even in Australia,
if you put in a combination
of keywords in the search bar,
you're not going to be shown
the hotline banner,
but you're going to get information
that might actually aid a suicide attempt.
So what if we could use
the same algorithms
that these tech companies use
to tailor ads to us
to be able to identify and reach out
to individuals thinking of suicide?
And we use information, their age, gender,
language and geography,
to do so in a deeply personal
and engaging way.
So what does this look like?
Imagine, Amy, a 22-year-old girl
living in Sydney.
She lives with her housemates,
and despite her cheerful demeanor,
she's recently been having
thoughts of suicide.
She's tried talking to her family members,
but they haven't been
particularly helpful.
And today she turned to the search page
to find a way to end it all.
And as she's searching,
the algorithm triggers,
and on the very first line,
she sees an ad that leads her
to a landing page.
And that landing page is designed to lead
her away from a suicide attempt.
Now, on that page,
she's not met with overly
fluffy language or with directives,
"You have to do this,
you have to do that,"
but rather, she's met
with stories of other people
who've been where she is.
And after hearing their stories,
she finally decides to seek help
through one of the many options available.
We work together with a group of people
that have thought of suicide,
that have attempted suicide
as well as lost someone to suicide,
where together, we come up
with a list of keywords
that people are likely to search.
We come up with what
the ad is going to say,
and we come up with the look
and feel of the landing page.
Now, these ads and landing pages
need to be as engaging as possible.
Why is that?
Because we don't know if we're only
minutes away from an attempt.
That's why my team and I
are using extensive targeting,
for example, age, language,
gender and geography,
to be able to reach out
to these individuals
in a deeply personal way
where we can use the tailoring
to show different ads
and landing pages to different people.
So in Australia, for example,
what we found is that individuals
who are in their teens, perhaps,
will resonate,
and different imagery and different
wording will resonate with them
than say, somebody in their 40s or 50s.
For example, what we found
is that the younger generation
actually really like the calming
and distracting resources.
They really like the breathing exercises.
Whereas the older generation,
they don’t want to see any of that,
and they prefer direct, no-nonsense,
straight-to-the-point language.
So in Amy's case, that's what she'll see.
But imagine Robert,
a 55-year-old man
living in rural Queensland.
Due to the recent economic downturn,
he's been under a tremendous
amount of stress.
And because he's the breadwinner
and the man of the family,
he feels that he cannot talk to anyone.
Something we know that is not true.
And so he turns to the search page
to find out what would happen
to his life insurance policy
in the event of a suicide,
because he's still thinking
about his family.
And as he goes there,
because his age group
indicated they want direct,
no-nonsense, problem-solving language,
that's what he'll be shown.
And on every single landing page,
there's a welcome video.
And the person welcoming you
to that welcome video
is somebody from your age group.
This is so that for every single
person in that dark time,
they'll be shown an ad and landing page
tailored as closely as possible to them.
Now we've run this trial in Australia
and what did we find?
In just 19 days,
our campaign reached over 120,000 people
searching up distress
and suicide-related keywords.
Now when they're on the page,
we want them to consume content
that is likely to lead them
away from a suicide attempt
and that is going to promote help-seeking.
Now, the industry standard for engagement
is approximately three percent.
That is, three percent of individuals
who land on the page
will engage with the page
in a meaningful way.
We found an engagement rate
of over 22 percent.
That's over seven times
the industry average,
suggesting there's a real need
for this type of intervention.
Furthermore, we're also
developing pages for Aboriginal
and Torres Strait Islanders
as well as Mandarin-speaking
populations in Australia.
Now we're doing this in several different
countries in several different ways.
For example, in Indonesia, where I'm from,
mental health stigma is so bad
that your own family might put you
in a makeshift cage
for having a mental disorder.
And there are over 21 unique
regional dialects.
Now we're using geographic targeting
to show different dialect pages
to different locations.
For example, if you live
in Semarang in central Java,
you'll see the ad and landing
page in bahasa Java.
If you live in Palembang,
you're going to see the page
in bahasa Palembang.
Now our pages are already
being used in Kidul Mountain,
which is an area with some
of the highest suicide rates
in the entire country.
And we're getting reports
that it's resonating really well
with people.
Why is that?
Because when you speak
the national language,
you speak to their minds.
But when you speak the regional language,
the language they spoke growing up,
you speak to their hearts.
I'd like to leave you with this.
We have an entire industry
with the technology,
the data and the means
to reach out to people who need it.
Rather than just tailor ads to them
and sell them things.
And this cannot replace.
the role of relationships and communities.
But given that most people still don't
seek help prior to a suicide attempt,
this could play an important
piece of the puzzle
in making sure that every
single person in their dark time
is met with an outstretched hand
the same way someone saved me.
Whether it’s a tap on the shoulder,
a text message
or even an internet ad.
Thank you.
(Applause)